hi everyone thank you for joining us for
our opening webinar for imaging
program this program is a celebration of
science photography and making
observations of the world around us
through photography
so through this webinar photography
tutorials we're gonna be and other
social media posts we're going to be
giving you the tools that you need to
take some really interesting
observations of the world around you and
share them with us in with that I'm
going to head I'm going to hand this off
to Erica reinfeldt is the the outreach
coordinator at the Koch Institute so
take it away Erika thank you so much
Brian all right let me pull my screen up
here and thank you to everyone who's
filled out the poll we'll be looking at
the results of that in just a little bit
but let me I'm gonna start things off
with an intro and then we'll jump into
the car conversation with our expert
photographers all right
so hopefully everyone can see this now
and before I move into introducing our
speakers I just want to tell you a
little bit about who I am and why I'm
here and I'm gonna go I'm gonna move the
poll off the screen and let you end that
Brian if you are in control of that all
right so I am a scientist by training
I'm an educator in practice and as you
can see most of my career has been spent
looking at interdisciplinary work so hi
this is me this is me and our public
galleries here at the Koch Institute at
MIT and that's actually what I want to
talk to you about first this is the this
is I think the main reason Brian asked
me to be a part of this webinar and so
as part of my role I manage the public
galleries at the Koch Institute which is
mi t--'s Cancer Research Center it's
convergence of biology and engineering
and one of the central exhibits in our
public galleries is the image awards
exhibition so that's every year
scientists and researchers from MIT s
biomedical engineering Life Sciences
submit images and a
of judges who are made up of scientists
and artists and others choose 10 images
from we get about 150 every year and
they select 10 of those images to be put
on display in these 8 foot tall light
boxes on Main Street in Cambridge so
what you see here is a snapshot from our
2016 exhibition there's a cryogenically
frozen stem-cell on the left and then
we're ashes standing she's this is a
mosaic of synthetic polymers that are
interacting with various cell types
taken with fluorescence microscopy so
any image in the display has to meet two
key criteria it has to be visually
engaging and it has to be scientifically
compelling it can't just be a pretty
picture it has to tell a good story
about real research so in Ash's case she
was examining these interactions between
synthetic materials and cells to
identify promising candidates for new
materials to be used in biomedical
research and clinical applications so
it's a screening experiment which serves
as a bridge between discovery and
innovation ideas and actions and that's
one of the themes I think we want to
talk about in our exploration of science
photography that connection between
ideas and action but before we do that I
want to show you another view of this
image which is juxtaposed with images of
exploding stars taken by the Chandra
x-ray Observatory this was put together
by a former colleague of mine Kim Ark
and I think it's just a really beautiful
illustration of how scientific imagery
can be used to make connections between
different disciplines so on that note if
you if you were reading my earlier slide
you'll see that I spent a fair bit of
time in the museum world looking at how
people make sense of scientific images
do they see them as information or do
they see them as art and well worth a
graduate degree the answer of course is
yes they do and so to illustrate that I
have one more comparison that I want to
show you so this is the image on the
left was taken by the Hubble Space
Telescope to commemorate the 15th
anniversary of the satellites launch it
shows a star-forming nebula in the
constellation
in Serpens and then on the right is a
painting I admitted it's not a
photograph by Thomas Moran
Elizabeth Kessler from Stanford has
pointed out how the decisions that the
scientists made in the colors and the
framing of images taken with cameras on
the hubble space telescope really invoke
these 19th century paintings and
photographs as well in both their
composition and theme so this kind of
blue sky background and the towering
pillars and the light reflecting around
them it represents scientific knowledge
about the nebula where these stars are
being born but they also call to mind
this exploration of new frontiers so
with that connection between art and
science and mind I'm gonna set aside the
fancy telescopes and microscopes and
leave you with some more down-to-earth
pictures as I introduce our first
speaker
I'll introduce Felice Franco who is a
research scientist in the department's
of chemical engineering and mechanical
engineering here or there at MIT she's
an award-winning science photographer
and her most recent book is picturing
science and engineering and it's
published by MIT press
she teaches an online EDX course making
science and engineering pictures a
practical guide to presenting your work
I've known Felice for a number of years
now we've worked on both education
workshops and on image and on this image
awards project and so I am delighted
that she's going to be our first speaker
and share her experience as a science
photographer wonderful can can you can
you hear me
it's wonderful to be here
I want to thank Erica and and Bryan for
inviting me I'm really delighted to do
this on a beautiful day like today and
wrap our head around something that is
beautiful and something that is somewhat
of a distraction if I could call it that
but it's it's a real joy to be with all
of you and thank you for coming I am now
I'm going to share I hope play my screen
Thank You Erica and Bryan for inviting
me
I'm so delighted and I can't wait to
talk to Keith and look at his amazing
pictures which we're all going to be
astounded by but my whole thing is going
to try to explain to you why I do what
I'm doing
Goethe wrote that which we know we have
first seen well let me tell you when I
make photographs I see things that I've
never seen before
obviously but I also see that it is a
means of discovery I'm constantly asking
questions whenever I take a picture of
some sort of scientific phenomena this
is an old picture that I did not take
from many years ago this kind of started
me in my whole new world taken out of
from a lab that George Whitesides ran it
Harvard it's a little complicated but
I'll quickly tell you that it is water
that is spreading out on a surface and
stopping at what we're calling
hydrophobic lines that's what started me
on my whole new journey because that's a
picture that they made and I said to
them we could do better and we did this
is the same phenomena where the
hydrophobic lives are preventing the
water from blending together that is in
fact what the science is about this was
my job to help them communicate the
science better this is Allison ass toes
image of material that she made that
she's studying in mechanical engineering
it's a fine image this is the image that
I made of the identical material I hope
you see the difference if you don't see
the difference I'm in real trouble
but basically what I'm trying to do is
engage you to look more clearly at the
research here's an image that I got off
of the law online and it's a picture of
something called ferrofluid this is the
picture that I made many years ago of
ferrofluid that I guess people still
enjoy looking at barrel fluid is oil
suspension of small iron
particles and when you put magnets next
to it it responds to the magnetic field
I made this for book that George
Whitesides and I did called on the
surface of things it for me most of this
is about getting you to see and to first
look to engage you and to get you to
understand that making beautiful images
and honest images which I could get to
at the end is a means of engagement
which i think is critical at this point
of our lives we've got to engage people
into what is going on in the research
labs and that's why I wrote the book
picturing science and engineering it's
for researchers but there's a lot of
photography basic photography in it and
I'm unabashedly introducing you to the
book I hope you could take a look at it
you can use a flatbed scanner it's quite
extraordinary what you could do with a
flatbed scanner I think if you set the
dpi correctly we I talked about using
backgrounds that kind of inform what it
is that we're looking at I show a lot of
microscopic images and and how using
certain techniques in microscopy can
advance the way it looks and also
frankly getting you to look that's what
I'm trying to do and the other part of
the book is all about the fact that
science in fact is everywhere and I
suggest that when you make pictures of
everything around you it's a means of
getting you to ask questions what it is
it what is it that exactly I'm seeing if
we had we had more interactivity I would
ask you what it is that you think you're
looking at and what you are looking at
is the glass cover of a sauteing pan and
I'm sauteing different peppers the thing
about this example is that I made it
with my phone and years ago I used to
tell the scientists you really can't
take great pictures with your phone well
I've changed my mind
I it's quite remarkable even walking
down calm as I
remember distinctly seeing these trees
for whatever reason they were wrapped
around with cellophane and I was looking
at these Assemblies of drops around the
crease there is a scientific reason for
the reason why that they are lining up
everywhere is science and why not start
making pictures of it mice's just more
fun I got this device where I put my
phone on the microscope it was it it was
it was a device that it easily puts it
allows you to see it and these are just
coffee bubbles that are kind of doing
their thing
I'm also very involved with finding the
metaphor sometimes you actually cannot
always take images of what the science
is so trying to find some sort of
photographic metaphor in this situation
on top we're trying to describe what
binary needs this is the the way
computers talk to each other this is the
inside of a music box and the notes go
on off on off and that is a suggestion
of a metaphor here's where I am in fact
putting a lot of pieces together of
photographs to make an image that
actually doesn't exist the image exists
but the thing that you're seeing doesn't
really exist hopefully is telling you a
story of something called remote epitaxy
which is too complicated to go into but
these are all pieces of pictures that I
put together but in the end I always
discuss with the researchers to maintain
the scientific integrity in your images
and that is a long conversation that
perhaps we'll have at some point for
example when I made this picture of a
yeast colony out of Jerry things lab
what I decided to do was to delete the
petri dish because I was blown away at
what was going on in this yeast yeast
colony the detail was astounding and I
wanted you to only pay attention to that
so idly
the petri dish the question is was I
permitted to do so and that is again a
long conversation that perhaps we might
have someday I say yes because the data
was not manipulated this is the data not
the petri dish so there we go there's a
little hint of what I do and it's a real
joy to be with you guys
I will stop sharing thank you so much
Feliz all right so what we want to do
now is turn things over to Keith and
he'll give you a little taste of what he
does I think those of you out there will
notice that we've we've chosen these two
folks for very particular reasons they
complement each other beautifully so
we're gonna hear from Keith momentarily
and then we'll then we'll have a little
discussion we'll get the two of them
actually talking to each other about
these science photos and we'll start to
take some questions from your audience
from you in the audience again using the
Q&A feature so let me introduce Keith
Keith is a celebrated underwater
photographer working at the intersection
of art science and technology to
showcase the visual complexity of
underwater environments from coral reefs
to coastal rivers to the wide open sea
he is an assistant professor of
photography at SUNY the Fashion
Institute of Technology and a visiting
artist at Massachusetts Institute of
Technology Sea Grant and the recipient
of the Ernest F Hollings Ocean awareness
award I met Keith um probably almost a
year ago because one of his planktonic
images is currently on display in the
Koch Institute public galleries so he
has the beautiful image of
dinoflagellates and I got to talk to him
about the story behind it but he takes a
lot of wonderful pictures and I'm gonna
let him tell you what he does oh thank
you very much for inviting me here can
you guys all see me and see my screen
um yes good to me okay great looks good
so thank you Erika and Brian it's
wonderful to be here and I have to say
it's just so inspiring to follow Felice
they're stunning images and the
photographic process so it's a real
honor to be here so thank you um I
thought I would talk today about what
it's like working with conservation
based organizations and being fortunate
to travel around the world to use the
art of photography in ocean photography
in particular to inspire awareness and
conservation this picture here is an
aerial photo of tropical coral reef from
about a thousand feet within the remote
Fijian Islands of Tortola the photograph
was captured on board
small helicopter with the doors removed
sitting outside the helicopter I was
harnessed and tethered in with the wind
blowing and you could communicating with
the pilot via headsets to get the right
pitch angle and image here for the next
few minutes I'd like to take you on a
journey beneath the waves underwater
photography is a challenge we're limited
by air light time depth animal behavior
just to name a few the constraints I
like this image of me diving because
it's uh it captures the strobes
illuminating the reef at depth the
wavelength of red is absorbed and the
ocean appears of blue gray but with the
addition of light I'm able to reveal
vibrant colors in the Galapagos Islands
I was on an assignment focusing on
biodiversity in sharks as we began to
swim back to the boat
I observed a large aggregation of sea
stars along the vast open sandy bottom
the Galapagos is known for its
biodiversity and ecosystems it's full of
mystery and intrigue but the colors of
these sea stars are natural but they
revealed for at light of the stroke
wildlife photography is about hours days
weeks maybe even years of patience
followed by an instant of action and
this photograph of a juvenile frigate
bird diving to catch a fish is an
example of that it was a behavior I
observed and spent two days waiting in
shallow water with the lens pre focused
the strobes above and below the water
the frigate birds never land in the
water these birds are unbelievable they
accelerate downward focusing on the fish
when they get near the surface they
virtually stall they place their head in
the water they switch between surface
vision underwater vision without
blinking catch the fish and then fly
away all in an instant I stopped the
lens snapped the picture looked it back
and with a little bit of luck I managed
to get just this photo here there are
also unexpected moments within the
tentacles of a jellyfish is a school of
juvenile trevally that seeks shelter if
you look closely you can see that I cap
eye you can see them right in the
tentacles to capture this image I
inverted myself under the water giving
the fishes perspective of what life must
look like through the waves into the
clouds in the sky oftentimes I
collaborate with scientists and I often
experiment with
other ways to visualize marine
environment this photo one of my
colleagues using a fluorescent strobes
to survey the coral reefs the
psychedelic colors emitted by
fluorescence light showcase another way
of looking at art in nature while at the
same point the colors may lead to a
deeper understanding about the health of
our corals sometimes I'm on assignments
in Indonesia or other places around the
world
diving with scientists setting out to
find and discover new possible species
of coral this is one that's being
described as a flower like pattern that
is unlike any other known species people
often ask what does it like to travel
with the on assignment and actually the
most stressful part of my job is so
nervously checking all the luggage and
bringing all the equipment everywhere I
need to go and just to give a sense of
the kind of equipment that I have these
are the housings that are all broken
apart as they're ready to be cleaned and
assembled I'm currently working on a
multi-year project entitled space to see
photographic journey into Stellwagen
bank National Marine Sanctuary
just 25 nautical miles off the coast of
Boston it's part of a Hollings ocean
awareness award to showcase the
surprising diversity of marine life off
our coast
to accomplish these images as part of my
process I'm working with students to
modify and prototype wireless camera
systems that enhance image making we're
bringing students into the field to
experience a local marine wildlife our
process is to conduct plankton tows
bring the living samples back to a lab
to be photographed under a microscope
and we're inspired by the work of
scientists at MIT Sea Grant where we're
experimenting with a variety of photo
microscopy image making techniques this
right this image was created adding a
drop of milk on the slide and just
filming the dynamic flow visualization
created by this Kleon or petrichor pod
there are other cool animals that are
all alien like on plankton litter living
in the ocean this is a larval crab and
if you look closely you can see it's
compound two eyes that are blue soon
this creature will drop to the seafloor
blah time and seafloor bottom and become
a tiny full formed crab as a wildlife
photographer I apply my image-making
skills to the micro scale this
composition of three serration is
currently on exhibit to mit public
galleries and once a University's back
open
I encourage all of you to join in visit
on this one magical day working with a
team of scientists naturalist and boat
captains I slipped into the water with a
wetsuit snorkel 360 multi camera system
looking to film what we thought was a
basking shark moving on the surface
to my surprise instead of encountering a
basking shark it was an enormous 3,000
pound great white shark later identified
his large March did the only thing I
know how to do which is keep the camera
stable and captured 17 glorious seconds
of footage from tip to tail that can be
viewed in an immersive virtual reality
experience Photography really has the
power to change our understanding of the
world around us and it is my lifelong
goal to use the artistry of underwater
photography to transform public
perception that sparks our imagination
inspires conservation and builds a local
stewardship about the extraordinary
underwater wildlife and to connect
residents in New England with the local
marine wildlife just off our shores
thanks thank you so much Keith all right
I think what I'd love to do now is bring
Keith and Felice back on the screen both
of them together
and I see some questions are starting to
come in on the Q&A but I'll just start
things off to note that so we've seen a
huge even in what 10 minutes a huge
diversity of subjects of equipment of
ideas environments and so we could talk
for hours and hours about the specifics
of each of those things but in thinking
about it as a collection of science
photographs all these things have things
in common they're good science
photographs so in your mind as a
photographer what makes for a good or
great science photo gulp well I like to
start with the easy ones well yeah
looking at kids work there's your answer
I mean it's just a you know you want to
but you want to look I think that's the
first thing what do you think you
absolutely I think the power of
observation is so critical I mean I
think so often people think you just go
into the field you just take a picture
and you just find these moments but
really it's a matter for me watching and
learning observing
and after watching it for a while you
begin to be able to at least predict
moments in the wildlife and the things
that are happening and so I think that I
agree with you 100% filiz the
observation is probably the most
important and pre visualizing what you
want to make for an image and and yet at
the same time leave open the surprises
yes you know that picture that I made an
attorney ago a ferrofluid when I put
those magnets under the Gluck immaterial
I had no idea that I was going to find
those shapes happening I had some idea
but and don't you find that you know you
can kind of get lost in the process that
once you start seeing things that you
didn't imagine you kind of stay with it
and maybe even get better pictures as
you go along
do you think absolutely I think you know
there's so much of the world where
you're you know you're trying on
something and then your eye gets open to
another way of doing something and you
follow into to capturing those images or
you know I think in part that's even why
collaboration is so wonderful you learn
something a little bit new and then you
try and experiment and while so often
for me I have a mental map of what I
want to photograph I mean so often that
isn't what I see it's the other things
that happen in sort of being ready for
those opportune moments of life just
sort of shifting for those that are
prepared for that or is really where
life gets very exciting for me well you
can see it in your photographs you're
passionate about it and we feel it Chris
it's so remarkable the way you do that
see your your work the main difference
among a gazillion other things is that I
am in control of my images I know you
know basic basically I work in a studio
where I control the lighting and
whatever else I can in fact control you
are certainly in control technically up
to a point but you never know what's
going to happen at the last minute you
have to figure you have to be prepared
as your equipment appears if you're
quite
there is a question from somebody what
what kind of a camera do you use for
undergrad undergraduate this I'm dealing
with undergraduate what camera are you
using I use a Canon 5d Mark 4 but as I
like to say and I use a CNC under order
housing and do all Y as 250 strobes but
what I like to tell people is is that
it's not the camera that makes the
photograph
it's the photograph itself and I think
when you look at felices and certainly I
feel for myself that a lot of it is
about making an image and there's always
a fancier camera there's always more
lights there's always more equipment and
always just adds complication and I
think that so much of image making is
learning how to actually create the very
thing you wanna be creating and I can't
stress this enough I spend a lot of time
even just waiting on repetition of
animals doing the same behavior because
if I see it once I try and capture that
again and I'm sure in the studio you
start to see things and then tweak it
just a little bit here and there and
life is full of that constant adjusting
and nuance which is what makes
photography so fun so fun I'm glad you
said worried it's fun yeah now in this
process though you're making some
editorial decisions right you're
deciding something I'm gonna photograph
this and I'm not gonna photograph that
how do you make that decision
that's called I'm stressed always on
that because sometimes in life they're
these moments where everything is
happening at once and how do you focus
or how do you even know where to stand
um and at some point experience gives
you how to position yourself where
you're more likely to see success than
less but so much of it is a matter of
sort of focusing on once I commit to
something I focus on that and try my
best to to work that problem through
visually and I tend to you could see in
my images that I shoot up to in sequence
that it's about like really moving and
positioning and making something better
sometimes you get it just on the first
glance like that frigate bird but I
waited for that shot and was prepared
for it but in other instances if it's
stationary sometimes I'm
tinkering with lights I'm trying to move
myself on making stability and so
there's a lot of work to make the image
just the way I sort of I see it at that
moment and I wonder if Lisa if that's
your same process - it's a little
different because I I sort of I have an
assignment to it picked a particular
phenomenon and in a way it's it's giving
me a parameter to work with in which I
enjoy that otherwise you could go crazy
you know and the thing and the thing
about and the same thing with you but I
understand the science of what I'm photo
God photographing house is background so
not as deep as the scientist no
understands but the very least I can
have what I what I do is I have a
conversation going with the researcher
and try to understand the the real bring
it down to the essence of what it is
that you're trying to say so I'm limited
in that it's it's not about making it
pretty I think science is already
beautiful
it's just revealing the beauty that's
already there but for me it's more
there's it's stripped more stringent in
a way it's just a beautiful way of
describing it and I think it's really a
visual language of removing the essence
to just get at the core of how you want
someone's eye to move to understand the
very things you want to convey
photographically or visually it's very
powerful yeah there's a question in the
in the QA about modification of
photographs after you've got that shot
what do you do to then present it and
this gets into the scientific integrity
that you were talking about but this you
have this these raw images and you know
at National Geographic is gonna is she's
saying the editor says we don't want
things that are stitched together we
want minor adjustments only how do you
tell a clear story and preserve the
integrity of the raw image I mean I
think that's the art of photography is
is using the right equipment to get the
right job and to get the right photo and
so all of my photos that you have seen
have not been altered in really any way
other than just some minor levels and
stuff like that
I don't crop in the lens is the choice
of what I'm using in my ability to
interact with the animals to get that
and editors and when you're looking to
sort of document something you have to
be true to what your image is if you're
going to find our gallery or its
abstraction and you're not documenting
you know you feel free to manipulate and
do as you wish but you certainly have to
acknowledge that the the key part is
again it comes with practice and
experience doing that and one of the
things that digital gives you that's so
wonderful is that as you learn if you
see you keep cropping in then you need a
different lens or you need to get closer
to your subject if you see that the
colors are always blown out then you
need to adjust your lighting so you can
learn on the fly for what you tend to
like as an artist as a photographer to
make those adjustments and help yourself
in the future so that you're improving
over time yeah and and you know this I
have a whole chapter on image
manipulation III because I am
documenting research I am very very
limited to any sort of manipulation or
enhancement there are guidelines that
the journals suggest that you you don't
do but when I do anything like for
example when I deleted the petri dish I
always say that I have done the
following whenever there were in the
caption I do not consider myself an
artist I would never I would never show
that image without somewhere saying that
this is what I've done and so there are
so there are rules in science and the
the problem is if you really really
think about photography itself is a
manipulation of reality you know the
camera that you use is going to give a
different picture than my camera and so
that the essence of photography is you
are manipulating what we're seeing yeah
it's it's an issue illusion it's I mean
it's clear I'm and that's what makes
photography so powerful is that you can
create a point of view through an image
in many ways you know I can be close in
in a reef scene for instance you could
be close to fish and give an illusion
that there are fish everywhere all
around but maybe it's just this one rock
that has something and so your point of
view on what you're documenting or
really has tells helps to tell the story
and you know for me that's that's the
fun of it is the perception of what
people see oftentimes you know on the
side of a road there's like a you know
you'd see like a hawk or something and
sometimes you take out a long lens and
you photograph and you think you're in
the middle of nowhere but you're right
in an urban city you know it's really
fun I'm seeing a lot of questions about
specific equipment and editing tools so
that's something that people are
interested but also where I'm hearing
what tips do you have for getting the
most out of cameras on a phone so for
this everyday photography right the
first thing is use it a lot and more
important after you use it edit you have
got to start looking at how you're
making the pictures and in that process
you will get to be a better photographer
you'll see that you left you see the
problem is for all of us is that we know
what we want to look at and we're
assuming that the viewer outside of
ourselves is going to see what we see
but when you have a tree branch growing
out of somebody's head the viewer is
going to see that even though you didn't
see it when you took the picture so I
think that you know there's not a whole
lot you could do that I could do with my
what I call my real camera but the
beauty of the phone is that you you can
quickly make an image with which I could
not I couldn't have taken that those
pepper in that pepper image 20 seconds
later because the picture was gone
and so it is in fact the wonderful part
about having the phone but you in the
end I really think you have got to start
paying attention and looking at them and
start deleting them because I can't but
you know might my colleague not my
colleagues but my friends they have so
many images they don't even know where
to even look and it's you they're not
learning anything and I think that's the
key to learn something yeah I agree with
that and I would just add I think to
think about intent of what what do you
want to show with this big image I think
one mistake people do a lot is they just
push the button constantly you know just
shot shot shot shot shot-shot-shot and
then hope for one of them to be right
but if you pause and look at which one
you like and then begin to ask yourself
what do I want to say with this picture
what would be important to me you know
what is the main focus what is around it
do you want movement those are all
elements that go through my mind all the
time in taking a picture so I would use
it more as what story do you want to say
shoot shoot a lot but not with intention
shoot
not just boom boom boom boom boom boom
but rather shoot lots of things in your
daily life and ask yourself which ones
you like and have fun with it I think
the most important thing of all I could
recommend to everyone is there's nothing
I like more than having an assignment
and having to go do my photography and
that joy and love is what you should
really focus on what have you learned
from a photo that you've taken where
you've looked at this and said oh I know
what I want to do next or I I know what
I shouldn't have done or what I what I
want to avoid how do you lose your own
photographs as a learning tool there's a
lot that I shouldn't have done which in
fact is this is why looking at your
pictures is a means of getting to be a
better photographer it's it's for me
it's mostly technical issues that I've
screwed up on and the fun thing is that
you as you make the mistakes you get to
be better what what else is new it's
like with everything in life right
you know I I think that is it couldn't
be more correct you have to look at what
you take and really study what is
working for you and what isn't and the
other thing that I I think people
discredit is I practice an awful lot I
think I practice with the dexterity of
my hand my strength my being able to
hold things up and if you want an easy
analogy I would think of it as a golfer
you know I can putt I'm not particularly
good but people still Tiger Woods still
putts all day long every day practicing
and stuff and I think there is a muscle
memory that happens on this and I do do
a lot I spend a lot of time staying
using the equipment frequently and being
very comfortable with all of the
interactions of it and I think that
helps out a lot yeah and you know and
you know it's not going to work because
because you've done it you've made the
mistake and that in a way I find that
I'm I'm a better photographer than I
used to be I mean when I don't feel that
way then I think I mean I'd better give
up but I know that I shouldn't do a
particular thing because it's not gonna
work so I in a way I save time right and
that's the other thing is to not hold
yourself to a standard to allow images
not to work and to recognize that you
know a lot of times I've tried things it
doesn't work out mmm hopefully it leads
to something that does but everything
isn't in an instant of an answer there
are many problems that take time to work
through or years of life to be able to
build towards those achievements it's
not just an immediate one-day
gratification rather a life of working
on it my goodness this sounds a lot like
the process of doing science yeah
imagine that we have a question along
those lines from the Q&A here saying in
the field of bio art to the
cross-disciplinary interaction between
artists and scientists seeks to redefine
the questions or perspectives being
asked in research so we'd love to hear
what you think about the that approach
as opposed to the role of the the artist
or the photographer is a scientific
documentarian
I'm forgive me I'm not quite sure the
dialogue between yourself as a science
photographer and research in this
process of foot
rafi redefining this questions being
asked in the research that you're not
just observing the science from the
outside your process is a part of well
again Carol and I hope I paraphrase that
accepted Lee
so the I'm not I'm not the artist so I
might be the wrong person to ask us up
because ultimately for me it is the
science that I want you to look at I
don't want you you can if you want think
that these these are artful but I don't
want
III do have colleagues and friends who
are artists who are use science as a
means of depicting you know their their
art this is this is wonderful and I
gather there are there's a real symbol
and symbiosis that can go on between the
artist and the scientist but that's not
me and so you'll forgive me but I can't
really make get you a good answer maybe
you could talk about that key yeah I can
a little bit but I think that that's
such a wonderful point that you know as
a perspective from a photographer yours
is from the science point of view even
though it translates into oftentimes art
and I think people confuse it you have
an intention with your photographs yes
and that intention is how you are
communicating and visualizing it and
that's very it's wonderful different
from the artists science exactly exactly
and you know it shows in what the
process is and what how people work
which is very important from what what
vantage point you're coming from for
making your own work on yeah thank you
and in in my instance I often uh you
know I'm collaborating with scientists
and I feel very fortunate that I'm with
people who you know help to tell me or
show me what is important or what is
currently happening there and so we're
collaborating a lot to be able to try
and show these things often they're
they're hard concepts to sort of find
but the the partnership I find a very
stimulating
role in terms of trying to communicate
these issues trying to support work that
they're doing trying to reach a public
and so I in in some instances I try to
transcend a few different roles in
images sometimes really documenting
something this is this is what's really
happening others trying to inspire
people and letting the story of science
come through on that and so and
sometimes it's several images to sort of
convey those those multiple points
through but I feel fortunate that
helping me you know if you look at a
rock and someone points out to you why
that rock is of significance and then
you photograph it in a way that's
interesting all of a sudden the story
behind that rock becomes much more
meaningful than at first glance looking
at it and sometimes we get confused with
what is a very powerful image which is
what is a very powerful image that tells
us a story we want a community and they
could be the same they could be
different and lots of variations in
between but I enjoy that that part of my
process I think I think one of the
reasons why I started at MIT over 25
years ago and it's can't believe it but
it took a while for the researchers to
understand that I was not making my art
that I was working for them I was
serving them and once they got it then
we flew but I am in the service of the
research community I think I think you
know we don't have you're collaborating
scientists on the line which perhaps was
an oversight on our fall but I imagine a
lot of them would say you know this
photograph that you took of my research
it helped me think about what I want to
do next in this experiment or how I'm
thinking about the science how I'm
communicating my science so I think the
photographs can also be a tool for
shaping absolutely thank you for saying
that and I'm told that is in fact the
case but it's not but I'm also working
on more so now on workshops on graphics
because all scientists have to create
figures for their journal submissions
and you and it's a collaborative effort
we company as a
we come together virtually and you would
be surprised by how thinking about what
it is that they want to say in the
figure is a clarification in their own
mind about their science thinking about
how to visually express it is a means of
clarification which is what Keith was
saying as well yeah it couldn't agree
more
I mean observation again it goes back to
looking at how do you see things how do
you express things and visually
communicating something and I think one
of the wonderful things about being at
MIT is that the scientists are also
engaging at the forefront of like trying
and experimenting and pushing things and
so it allows both visual stimulation of
how do we show this in a new and
exciting way and how do we actually
understand it and so I find that
collaboration to be very personally
we're very rewarding yeah sounds amazing
I think we've got time for one more
question so I'm gonna pull one from the
chat which is do you ask your co-workers
or and or friends for feedback on your
photography or their perspective to see
how you look at it and find the message
your audience gets from it talk about
the feedback you get on your images well
I will tell you I it's funny how you
maybe it's my genetic composition but I
you you remember the bad stuff what I'll
never forget I gave a talk in Scotland
it was a big audience and it was kind of
the beginning of this area of my life
and somebody got up in the audience and
said you know your your pictures are
really ugly that was the word this
person used and so you know it threw me
back a bit but I remember that whereas I
don't remember what see I don't really
believe what people say now everybody's
gonna say they're nice I mean what are
they gonna say no they're not nice don't
you think you I couldn't be more I think
you need a close group of colleagues who
can give honest and real feedback what I
like to say is and I love my mom dearly
but if I asked her if she likes these
pictures I overwhelmingly get these are
wonderful and I love them but you need
real feedback in comments and I think
one of the things is that in terms of
teaching photography in art schools is
is trying to get that kind of real
feedback so you learn how to present you
learn how to sort of articulate and in
some ways you hope you get honest
feedback that doesn't just say I love it
but could you have focused a little more
on this or should you have done this and
I think being hypercritical at least of
myself I know I'm very hard on myself
and with a few people who I really trust
who to give honest feedback for how to
push me harder is is what I'm looking
for and then you know sometimes when you
get something right you know it just
feels good but you need that you'll
feedback you into photography school I
don't know that I got a MFA from Parsons
uh-huh design and technology and then
now I teach photography both previously
at Parsons and then now currently I
teach photography at SUNY the Fashion
Institute of Technology do you think is
this okay
Erika tip for me to ask a question of
Keith I think so no I'm not I'm not I'm
not trained at all in photography and
I'm do you think you have to be trained
in formal training no not at all I think
I think the thing I think what formal
training does is help you think about
some of the problems that maybe you
didn't and maybe to learn along the way
of and to work through some problems
especially when you're very early in
your career but I think that the many
some of the most famous photographers I
know at least amongst one of them are
not formally trained at all but I think
that learning a lot of people have a
natural eye but then learning to sort of
nurture that and express it is not
always something that comes natural and
easy to everyone and I think school and
or courses and workshops can help sort
of begin to give you the vocabulary
begin to give you the things to look at
that can be helpful instead of spending
years of learning how to do something
maybe you can learn a little bit quicker
but I think the most important
is to understand at least yourself what
you're really visually communicating and
what you're really trying to communicate
because luck while it happens only
happens when you really are prepared I
think yeah and so the key is to know how
to make your picture so that if someone
asked you to do it you could really go
out and do it not just be like oh my god
how am I going to get this image and
even though that may be how you feel
internally doesn't need to know like my
own stress of life kind of things yep
that is excellent insight and so this of
course is the kickoff for a whole
program for people to go out and take
images and see the world so I think what
I'd like to do is bring Brian back to
talk a little bit about the logistics of
what what's gonna happen on social media
for the next two weeks as we as we flood
things and then maybe we'll close out
with one last question yeah thank you so
much Lisa Keith and Erika that's great
conversation so yeah as Erika said this
is a kickoff to two weeks of imaging
science of encouraging you all to go out
go out in your back yard around your
houses apartments and take some pictures
and explore and discover through the
lens of photography I'm so to help you
along the way we have a couple of things
set up for you so the first is we have
this hashtag MIT M imaging science so if
you follow that hashtag on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram we're going to be
posting tutorials on macro photography
Astro photography basic camera settings
they there are six tutorials they're on
a lot of the questions that we actually
we haven't got a chance to answer
they're actually going to be answered in
those videos whether you use a cell
phone or DSLR or whatever camera you
have they're designed to be helpful to
help you try a new camera techniques
that you may not have tried before
we're also would love to see your images
so along with following that hashtag and
seeing some of the resources that we
post please take your own photos tag
them with that hashtag and at the end of
this program on June 20th we're going to
be featuring some of your uploaded
photos as part of that closing webinar
so with
but I'm gonna hand it over to Erica to
ask one more question of both of our
panelists all right so my last question
is we've got we've got several dozen
people out there ready to take photos
and I hope many more on social media who
will watch the recording of this later
so what's your advice for them what do
you hope for them as they explore the
world with their handheld cameras these
next two weeks and beyond do it don't
think about it don't ask anybody should
I do it just go ahead and shoot and if
you hopefully you will love it if you
don't then don't do it
really it's about like ya couldn't agree
more and find something that's
accessible don't make a problem a
photographic problem harder don't you
know we can't go anywhere right now
so photograph something that's right
around you and make it really
interesting and what I tell everyone is
enjoy the process of photography for me
it's a love and I think you really got
to find something that you like taking I
look forward to seeing these images and
so I'm excited to see what you guys
shoot but really find something you like
I
I'm gonna add one more thing think about
excuse me
think about how it looks to someone else
think about how the viewer is going to
see your picture because you you know
how to look at it and just consider am I
really showing a the first-time viewer
what it is that I want them to see thank
you so much I wish we could keep talking
but as you said it's a beautiful day
outside and there's a there are a lot of
things to discover so thank you both so
much for being a part of this oh and our
pleasure and thanks Brian for putting it
together and everybody look for us on
hashtag mi TM Imaging Science
you